[Music]
new season of girls Sena premiere on
Sunday congratulations on that people
love that show
it must be you know Lena is such a
fascinating Lena Dunham such a
fascinating show she's brilliant she's
such a great actress she's got a great
point of view it must be fun working
with her you too time to have a good
partnership yeah we really do it's it's
a strange very positive relationship for
a long time now it's been in more than
half a decade we've never we never get
in fights about anything and we're kind
of in sync you know everyone's all we
have to do press together that's the
only time where it gets weird because
she considers me she calls me her father
brother son figure so sometimes I'm like
mentor father but other times she's
mentoring me and sometimes I'm like a
goofy brother but every once awhile I
get a photo shoot I'll try to get us a
like touch each other or like lean into
each other and that's uncomfortable that
feels weird so like we faked trying I'm
almost imply like it can get a little
sexual is that what you're saying you
don't want to get us sexy with each
other it's we yeah it's weird yeah it's
like so we did this one photo shoot for
the show iconic class and and they're
like can you guys like lean on each
other and on each other like on a bed
and I'm like that seems wrong and so we
got distance have you brought that
picture we got distance you haven't
picked on each other see how far away I
got yeah it's like you insisted I want
to be really far away from I'm an old
man she's giving you a talk about self
exploration and then recently we had
another photo shoot and we said I think
we're ready to touch a little bit right
if that's for a TV Guide magazine but
it's uncomfortable it doesn't look good
so you're uncomfortable in this photo I
don't well this is as comfortable as I
get let's take a look let's see this is
oh you can just Photoshop and bond out
the sad rabbi and you know I only have
one outfit I think you just realize -
was have you gone beardless ones last
tenant without a beard I accidentally
had an electric razor and tried to trim
and just lost a section so I had to
shave it all and my family hates me
without a beard they said scares
anything my daughter said you look like
a very old turtle it felt anti-semitic
yeah yeah and I do look I do look bad
they're like we hate your face your
mouth does weird things without the
beard and like it's half your face you
look kind of like this